we are asked which of the following
correctly identifies the areas of
consumer surplus producer surplus tax
revenue and deadweight loss in this
market after the tax so pause this video
have a go at it even if you struggle
with it it'll make your brain more
attuned to what who you worked through
it together
alright now let's let's work through
this together and I just really want to
understand what's going on here before I
even try to answer their questions so
let's first think about what's going on
before the tax so before the tax I have
this supply curve right over here in
blue and I have this demand curve where
they intersect gives us our equilibrium
price right over here and our
equilibrium quantity right over there
and if we wanted to look at the consumer
surplus it would be the area above this
horizontal line and below the demand
curve so that is our original consumer
surplus and our original producer
surplus is above the supply curve and
below this price horizontal line and so
the total surplus would be this entire
triangle right over here all before the
tax but they're not asking us before the
tax they want us to figure out
everything after the tax so what happens
do the tax well if we assume it's a tax
on each unit that is being supplied well
the effect it has and we see it here
they drew it for us is that shifts the
effective supply curve up and I say the
effective one because that's the one
that's going to affect the equilibrium
price or the new equilibrium price but
as we'll see there's some nuances in in
terms of considering the surplus so
first let's think about the consumer
well actually let me label the now price
with the taxes so this is now our
equilibrium price when we have the taxes
it's where our demand curve hasn't
shifted but where the existing demand
curve intersects with this new shifted
supply with tax curve and similarly that
point of intersection also tells us our
quantity with the taxes now
now that we've understood everything or
hopefully we have let's think about the
various surpluses and the dead late
weight losses and the tax revenues so
first let's think about the consumer
surplus
well the consumer surplus is going to be
the region above our new horizontal
price and below the demand curve so that
is this region R right over here that
still you have this consumer right over
here who would who was willing to pay a
lot but still has to pay less than that
even with the taxes so they're getting
this benefit more than they would have
needed in order they would have been
willing to pay more than the tax and so
they're getting this surplus and so if
you look at the entire market right now
the total consumer surplus after the tax
is R R is equal to consumer surplus and
this is all after the taxes consumer
surplus now what about the producer
surplus well if we weren't dealing with
the tax we would just look above the
supply curve and below this the
equilibrium price line and say hey maybe
it's that area but remember what's
happening from the producers point of
view the producer does not see this new
increased price at this quantity the
producer remember they don't get to keep
the tax revenue that they have to give
to the government so the producer
actually this is the price that the
producer sees so you can see this is
this is what what producers what
producers get after taxes after taxes
where I'd say net of taxes maybe a
better way to think about it net of
taxes and so this producer surplus is
going to be the area below what they're
getting from the market net of taxes and
above what they the price is at which
they were willing to produce various
quantities and so the producer surplus
is this area of V right over here so V
is equal to the producer producer
surplus and now what about the tax
revenue well the tax revenue is is
essentially going to be all of this
other part of the total surplus this is
what goes to the government
the difference between these two if the
producers did not have to give that tax
to the government then they would have
been able to keep all of this but this
right over here let me do this in a new
color
so this region right over here is what
the government is able to keep notice
it's this quantity and they get this
much tax per unit quantity and so this
area is the government - is a revenue to
the government so S Plus u is equal to
tax revenue tax revenue and then last
but not least what about the deadweight
loss well remember the deadweight loss
is the difference between the original
total surplus when we just let things
naturally go to equilibrium the
difference between that and now our new
total surplus which is now lower because
we have not allowed the market to just
function in a very natural way because
of this tax on quantity well as we said
before the original total surplus was
this entire triangle now the total
surplus is this trapezoid that's the sum
of all of these areas and so what we
lost is this area right over here
so that is the deadweight loss so T plus
W is equal to the dead weight loss and
we're done